[Musique]
dans un coin de cette cuisine centrale
associations collectivités et
institutions publiques sont autour de la
présidente de l'association autour du va
quoi un temps de restitution pour
montrer l'avancement de ce projet de
développement économique et social
l'une des étapes a été la validation
scientifique du projet alors cette étude
a permis en fait de révéler que le vacoa
est utilisé dans le monde entier comme
aliment santé
il contient très peu de glucides des
fibres là aussi il y a des vitamines c
et d et b aussi qu'ils sont utiles pour
le système nerveux extrêmement santé qui
amène une certaine sérénité instead
zénitude dans sa consommation
mais étant donné qu'on a beaucoup de
diabète et de maladies cardiovasculaires
à l'est de la réunion
il peut apporter une certaine diététique
à ces personnes qui ont besoin justement
d'aliments santé
le potentiel est énorme et chantal et il
a le savent après deux années de contrat
aidé et financé par le département qui
soutient la tresse du va quoi c'est
maintenant bénévolement qu'elle est de
ce projet et ce midi elles présentent
leurs créations
ce midi à l'apéritif akrad papa et chips
de papa ensuite en entrée salade de
papaye saumon en plat alors un sauté de
poulet et karine bauraud par
l'originalité c'est des textures et des
goûts qu'on ne trouve pas forcément
ailleurs
ah super projet surtout que c'est donc
l'entraînement ce projet là des années à
faire et à refaire pour trouver les
bonnes méthodes des bonnes recettes
aujourd'hui l'association à structurer
ses projets et rêves d'avenir sa part de
d'une passion déjà du lien social c'est
à dire comment j'évolue dans un groupe
comment j'arrive à avoir du plaisir
chaque jour à me lever et aller voir
d'autres personnes et autour de ça de
bada il ya une émulation finalement dans
les idées dans ce qu'on pouvait faire ce
qu'on pouvait mettre en place et surtout
on a travaillé le rêve on rêve de quoi
quelle va être notre idéal si demain on
devait travailler dans une structure
idéalement ce serait pour faire quoi et
dans quelle dans quel environnement et
c'est comme ça qu'on a construit le
modèle économique de l'association au
moment de la dégustation les sourires
semblent unanimes la motivation de ces
femmes leur permettra peut-être d'ouvrir
une nouvelle voie professionnelle
un livre de recettes des ateliers
culinaires un laboratoire et même un
restaurant l'énergie déployée en
recherche et développement
leur permet maintenant de voir plus
grand
[Musique]